y
[Música]
los resultados preliminares de las
elecciones presidenciales en irán le dan
la victoria al candidato
ultraconservador ebrahim raisi quien
cuenta ya con un 62 por ciento de los
votos contabilizados se espera que la
comisión nacional electoral entregue
resultados definitivos y sábado tenemos
análisis
la asamblea general de la onu aprobó una
resolución en la que pide detener el
flujo de armas hacia mianmar exigen
restablecimiento de la democracia y
aboga por la liberación de los presos
políticos entre ellos la detenida líder
nacional and sound sushi hoy en su
cumpleaños número 76 se registraron
nuevas manifestaciones en contra del
golpe de estado
la organización mundial de la salud
alertó sobre la expansión y aceleración
de los casos de kobe 19 en el continente
africano según la entidad la cifra de
contagios ha aumentado en un 52% durante
la última semana mientras la población
vacunada representa apenas el 1 por
ciento varias naciones imponen nuevas
medidas
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en paz 24
bienvenidos de nuevo yo soy liliana
valencia iniciamos en irán porque el
candidato ultraconservador ebrahim raisi
lidera la contienda con el 62% de los
votos para las elecciones presidenciales
que tuvieron lugar este viernes se
esperan resultados definitivos durante
la jornada de hoy
de los 28 6 millones de actas
contabilizadas brahin daisy cuenta con
más de 17,8 millones de sufragios según
los resultados preliminares entregados
por la comisión nacional electoral más
de 59 millones de iraníes estaban
llamados a las urnas en los comicios que
registraron un bajo nivel de
participación
participaron también un candidato
moderado y tres conservadores entre
ellos raíz y actual jefe del poder
judicial y quien está sujeto a sanciones
estadounidenses para realizar esta
información nos comunicamos con maría
teresa allá analista internacional y
coordinadora de la maestría de asuntos
internacionales de la universidad
externado de colombia que se conecta con
nosotros desde la ciudad de santa marta
bienvenida diabéticos recuadros como
analizamos los resultados de estas
elecciones marcadas por pocas opciones
políticas para los ciudadanos y por una
amplia apatía
muy buenos días a todos
hubo una ganancia en estas elecciones
una abstención mayor al 50% por primera
vez desde que siguió la revolución esto
sumado a que no hubo muchos candidatos
el consejo de guardianes el consejo de
la regla quienes son los encargados de
dictaminar quienes pueden ser candidatos
o no habría eliminado varios posibles
candidatos entre ellos por ejemplo el ex
presidente ahmed y negado sin embargo
llegaron a la final muy pocos y esto fue
lo que significó que no hubiera una
votación interesante para muchos para
los reformistas como lo llama de viajes
quienes quieren un régimen un poco más
libre esto no era una democracia y ya
estuvieron de votar en un principio
también llamar a un boicot a las
elecciones el boicot no les funcionó
porque habían muchas elecciones de ya
menos los mandos medios alcaldías
asamblea
y no les convenía perder esos votos y
perder esos puestos en sus posibles
victorias que tuvieran en mandos medios
es decir no funcionar huecos pero si
alcanzó hacer media y una gran
abstención ahora el resultado fue como
dijeron ustedes un personaje de la
derecha
y justamente eso lo queríamos preguntar
a nivel interno que le espera a irán
bajo la presidencia de ebrahim raisi
recordemos que se trata de un hombre
como usted lo dice sobre el cual pesan
señalamientos por su presunto rol en la
ejecución extrajudicial de prisioneros
políticos y de la amnistía internacional
pie que se reanuden las investigaciones
en su contra
realmente es un país donde se cometen
violaciones de derechos humanos todos
los días en todo momento es el alcanzó a
los años 80 en los últimos años había
una mínima libertad pesa díaz granados
sobre todo con el gobierno de ahmed y
negada con rareza se espera que se
retorne a una ultraderecha aunque se
hagan más estrictas las leyes con los
que sale en contra del régimen
aunque haya seguramente más
encarcelamientos y como dicen cada uno
rey dentro se astilló y eso no creen en
especial en algunos países del medio
oriente incluidos irán quiere decir yo
puedo hacer dentro de mis fronteras lo
que yo quiera porque yo tres rey de mi
castillo con esa lógica y con el
antecedente que tiene a esa esfera
más valoraciones a los derechos humanos
ahora derecha recalcitrante una derecha
muy estricta en el final la aplicación
de félix pues agradecemos el análisis de
nuestra invitada desde santa marta y
continuamos justamente hablando de irán
porque en 2018 el ex presidente de
estadounidense donald trump decidió
sacar a su país del acuerdo nuclear con
irán
la retirada conllevó también a sanciones
económicas a la república islámica que
han provocado un gran alza los precios
de los productos de importación y una
inflación que ha alcanzado el 48 por
ciento en el último año la llegada de
joe biden a la casa blanca ha supuesto
el reinicio de las negociaciones con
irán quien resulte electo en irán tendrá
el gran reto de estabilizar una economía
duramente golpeada por las sanciones
internacionales
en los bazares de irán los precios se
dispararon desde que donald trump rompió
el acuerdo nuclear e impuso nuevas
sanciones a la república islámica
técnicamente las exportaciones
estadounidenses a iran están prohibidas
sin embargo muchos comerciantes están
consiguiendo sortear las sanciones estas
nueces vienen de california
estos frutos secos tardan nueve meses en
llegar desde eeuu como antes
van a china luego de china dubai y de
uruguay irán en la factura dice que
vienen de china debido a las sanciones
los productos de importación son escasos
y caros la inflación es demasiado alta
un empleado ordinario ya no puede llegar
a fin de mes
abajo los eeuu
según el banco mundial la inflación ha
alcanzado el 48 por ciento en un año
este barrio de teherán está
especializado en la venta de piezas de
automóviles debido a las sanciones la
reparación de vehículos europeos se ha
convertido en un reto
la mayoría de automovilistas ya no
pueden permitirse comprar piezas
originales y recurren a copias más
baratas
y voy a quedarme con esta pieza también
necesitaría una luz de techo trasera
cuánto cuesta una luz trasera 190.000
en la última vez fueron 150.000 porque
no podemos conseguir las piezas
directamente así que recurrimos a
intermediarios turcos que nos las venden
algunos precios como las de las
pastillas de freno se han multiplicado
por diez
select
el grado sería mucho más fácil si se
levantarán esas sanciones
pero yo no creo en ellos el presidente
estadounidense joe biden ha decidido
retomar las negociaciones nucleares con
la república islámica de irán el mayor
reto del próximo presidente iraní será
obtener la retirada de las sanciones
económicas internacionales
hablamos ahora de mi amar porque la
asamblea general de las naciones unidas
adoptó una resolución no vinculante por
medio de la cual le pidió el cese
inmediato de la venta de armas a mianmar
y exigió a la junta militar golpista el
regreso a la democracia y la liberación
de los presos políticos entre ellos la
líder nacional and sanssouci
ella está cumpliendo 76 años y la fecha
ha generado nuevas manifestaciones por
parte de la ciudadanía que se tomó las
calles de las principales ciudades para
pedir su libertad con flores y pasteles
de cumpleaños la resolución contó con el
voto favorable de 119 países la
oposición de belarús y 36 abstenciones
entre ellas la de rusia y chica
es la declaración más fuerte de la onu
sobre mianmar una resolución que condena
a la junta militar que derrocó al
gobierno del país la asamblea general de
la onu ha anunciado oficialmente golpes
militares pocas veces desde los años 90
sin embargo uno de los principales
partidarios de la resolución el
embajador de mi hermana ante la onu
pidió una acción aún más contundente es
el primer funcionario de alto rango que
desertó desde el golpe
estamos tan decepcionados de que hayan
sido necesario casi tres meses para
aprobar esta resolución suavizadas
aunque no incluye muchos puntos
importantes para salvar la vida de la
población de mianmar y me ama
la resolución pide el restablecimiento
de la transición democrática del país y
la liberación de los funcionarios
gubernamentales detenidos sobre todo
insta la comunidad internacional a
contener el flujo de armas en el país
el borrador inicial incluye un embargo
de armas completo pero esa referencia
tuvo que eliminarse tras la oposición de
varios países de la asean la medida se
produce mientras la onu advierte sobre
una escalada de violencia
el tiempo es esencial la oportunidad de
revertir la toma del poder militar se
está reduciendo y la amenaza regional
aumenta el riesgo de una guerra civil a
gran escala es real the risk of lords
game y blue world will
informes denuncian que las fuerzas
gubernamentales incendiaron una aldea
entera en la región de mauá y el
miércoles varios testigos dijeron que
tuvieron que huir cuando los soldados
entraron disparando al lugar
las protestas diarias han sacudido el
país el levantamiento se ha enfrentado
con una brutal represión militar que ha
matado a cientos de civiles
en noticias del continente africano la
organización mundial de la salud alertó
sobre el incremento de los contagios y
muertes por kobe 19 durante la última
semana los positivos confirmados
aumentaron en un 52% y las muertes en un
32% esto mientras las campañas de
vacunación alcanzan apenas al 1% de la
población y varias naciones han tenido
que suspender las por falta de dosis
países como uganda y ponen nuevas
restricciones
la pandemia de coronavirus sigue
cobrando fuerza y debilitando a un
sistema de salud ya precario en tres
semanas el número de contagios diarios
en uganda aumentó de 100 a 1700 en este
hospital de kampala la atención es
palpable
las reservas de oxígeno que necesitan
nuestros pacientes pronto serán
insuficientes hoy podemos atender a 200
personas
voy a making pero cada día llegan más y
en algún momento no seremos capaces de
cubrir la demanda
[Música]
con las 900 camas que tenemos en este
hospital
ante el aumento de los contagios el
gobierno impondrá nuevas medidas de
restricción sanitaria están prohibidos
los viajes al interior del país y el
toque de queda nocturno se prolongará al
menos seis semanas más
uganda como el resto del continente
africano ha visto un veloz incremento de
los contagios
en áfrica que es de saab increased by
fitito en áfrica los casos han aumentado
en un 52% en la última semana y las
muertes han aumentado en un 32% por
ahora sólo se espera que la situación
empeore se ha vacunado menos del 1 por
ciento de la población africana
los mil millones de vacunas prometidas
por los miembros del g7 a los países más
pobres empezarán a entregarse sólo a
partir de septiembre
mientras tanto en algunos países de
europa las medidas contra el coi 19
están siendo levantadas paulatinamente y
en otros sin poner nuevas restricciones
al mismo tiempo que avanzan las campañas
de vacunación estas van desde el fin del
uso obligatorio de la mascarilla en
españa hasta la ampliación de las
restricciones en rusia que registró un
nuevo récord de contagios diario con 17
mil 906 en las últimas 24 horas
las mascarillas se acercan a su fin en
españa a partir del 26 de junio dejarán
de ser obligatorias en exteriores
volveremos con ello pues a disfrutar de
una vida en la calle sin mascarilla
sobre todo y a mí me gustaría rendir en
primer lugar tributo a los españoles y
españolas al conjunto de compatriotas
que han sido disciplinados todo este
tiempo con más de una cuarta parte de la
población española completamente
vacunada alemán ya retirado de su lista
de zonas de riesgo algunas partes de
españa junto a francia grecia y suiza
noruega también se está relajando a
partir del domingo la gente podrá
reunirse en grupos más grandes
habrá más visitantes extranjeros y los
bares y restaurantes permanecerán
abiertos después de la medianoche sin
embargo algunas partes de europa van en
sentido contrario en medio de un pico de
contagios los ciudadanos de lisboa y sus
alrededores no podrán salir de su zona
los fines de semana una medida que no
todos se han tomado igual
no ha habido ninguna mejora casi dos
años con el kobe y esta es la situación
de la crítica no puedo criticar las
medidas porque son realmente necesarias
como es necesario que la gente entienda
que esto aún no ha terminado es
comprenderse quisiera lo acabo mientras
tanto italia ha vuelto a imponer una
cuarentena de cinco días para quienes
lleguen desde reino unido la propagación
de la variante delta allí ha
una semana el levantamiento definitivo
de las restricciones paralelamente la
misma variante ha generado un récord de
contagios de moscú
por eso las zonas de aficionados en la
eurocopa permanecerán cerradas y se
mantendrá el cierre de los cafés y
restaurantes' a las 11 de la noche
así finalizamos por esta emisión en
france 24 pero los invitamos a visitar
nuestro sitio web de noticias
internacionales france24 puntocom y
información en inglés francés árabe y
español continúen con más también aquí
en france 24
[Música]